hello
happy Wednesday it's me Eric and your
your good pal Aaron Sampson how are you
doing it is it is a Thursday it is a
Thursday and we got a fun one
we're plans yeah go ahead Division 2
Division 2 beta we've actually played a
bunch of this game also at a preview
event so you're gonna see some of the
things that we saw there and then
tomorrow they're gonna do the end game
section of this beta so you'll get to
play some things that we did or did not
we hadn't we haven't like fully
confirmed exactly what the end game
section will be but if you want to see
what we played we already got that up on
our site otherwise hang with us today
and we'll do a lot of jumping jacks and
shoot a lot of bad guys yeah I can kind
of break down what's in the private beta
as it stands if you're playing or
thinking about playing right now you can
play main missions Grand Washington
hotel as well as the Jefferson Trade
Center you have the open world which has
five additional side missions control
points and activities and then you also
have dark zone and conflict which gives
you dark zone East and skirmish PvP mode
so maybe we'll hop in to some PvP as
well later but I go for about 90 minutes
to two hours a day oh you didn't tell me
that they Ubisoft had tweeted that like
if you play for like two to three hours
you might get a crash yeah there was a
tweet this morning that if you play they
recommended you restart your your game
every day yeah like two to three hours
probably three hours in my crash um also
in other news I don't know like right
before we started the stream Tay and I
were talking a bunch about anthem
endgame if you guys want to talk about
that they actually just started
releasing what their roadmaps gonna look
like for their uh their end game and
given that as a very like we're get
we're getting into it right now like
it's starting to become a crowded
crowded season for people who like
lifestyle games I know it's at least
what we call him here work games like
destiny division anthem fortnight
fortnight is having another season at
the end of this month
so yeah like we'll play some Division
two and we'll talk about whatever you
guys want to talk about and if you have
any questions about this game in
particular we've played a bunch I've
also played all three dark zones I mean
I played the level enabled versions of
it I have not played the like new
unrestricted dark zone which is gonna
rotate periodically yeah sorry we are
currently on PC I'm playing with a
controller though just stay aware of it
totally fine like I feel like for me
personally any time I play a third
person game on PC I'd still prefer
controller shoot you're but yeah so
right now you're pretty much a basic
agent right like no skills
yeah and through some of this and a
smoky cloud of smoke um it's interesting
the the onboarding process of this time
around so I'm trying to remember back to
division one which was a game by the way
that I think a lot of us liked a lot we
all felt that maybe the end game hadn't
really been fully thought-out and this
time around it feels like they they led
with endgame in their design and at
least that's what they've told us and
they're spending a lot of time thinking
about what you're gonna do after what
they've said is a 40-hour campaign oh
wow okay I mean they for those of you
who either play division or stop playing
the division they went through a lot of
very good updates as they as that game
progressed I know that the like last big
update from them was a really solid one
there's a bunch of like cool stuff to do
there's like even like a horde mode I
think but a lot of people might not have
experienced that because they dropped
off so you know I'm sure a lot of that
has gone into division 2 which is good
which is excellent which means more
people will be able to to play that and
I'm sure there's added layers here in
flavors that weren't in division 1 also
we're in a different setting we're now
Washington DC yes we're in Washington DC
the storyline is that it's seven months
later and I guess you didn't do a very
good job in New York because the virus
is everywhere now what's different this
time around is that there
our affections and the factions the way
it was described to us are more GTA san
andreas style they actually fight over
the map and control points on the map
you play this real quick
this is your base of operations which is
the White House there's also so there's
factions that fight over over the map
and there's also settlements that you
can upgrade other than just your main
base and they have stories and cutscenes
they're not just dead people with echoes
we're gonna walk in here let me get to
some of these questions you still have
to pay cash for storage space I think
you have to upgrade storage space from
what I've seen earlier but I haven't
played through this yet so apologies
we're kind of going through the very
very early parts of this beta kind of
like that opening area I almost feel
like I'll turn this up this is you
welcome to DC I'm Annie I run comps I'm
guessing the division alert brought you
here damn glad to see you let me show
you exactly how screwed we are ever
since the JTF imploded the city's become
a playground for murderers [ __ ]
there are several main factions and a
whole lot of bottom feeders sucking up
whatever the big dogs miss a few
civilians settlements are still holding
out against all this villainy
they need more help than we've been able
to provide especially since the division
network went dark um that's Kelso she's
one of the last surviving agents in DC
she's operating under the theater
settlement on a priority mission you
should go check in with her if anyone
knows how to get these systems back
online
it's her be able to customize there's a
new sheriff in town yeah we were using
the randomizer for this beta but it
seemed like there was a lot of
customization seem we're like we aged
wildlands in terms of there was a lot of
tattoos and and things you know it's
kind of funny so there's photo mode in
this game but uh the character models
eyes are kind of dead inside so I'd
recommend you put on some glasses if
you're gonna use photo mode question is
I don't know if you'll be able to take
the glasses off a member in Division one
if you chose glasses you were
duck with them for the rest of the game
find out so now you get to unlock some
skills okay so this part of the game is
a bit more grindy then I remember the
first one being actually let me get
through this part but you actually have
to unlock your second weapon and a
couple other things also
so like the drone in the seeker mine now
have this thing where you have to mash
the right motley son control you have to
match the right bumper a ton of times to
get them to do what you want them to do
which is it was a little confusing I
think it's gonna take some getting used
to so but I don't know let's go through
so you can actually have it like go
after a certain person this time around
right it's more specific but it's a bit
more complicated and I think that's
something people will just kind of get
used to so it sounds like there probably
is better customization Anki their
question was is there better
customization what you kind of answered
asked Aaron where to get time to play
this I mean like you got to choose cuz
it's just like work do the challenges
each week etc I mean if you're probably
playing Division two is like you're
probably not playing too many other
games I would imagine unless you know
you just kind of get through that and
then move on to your next game but yeah
it's definitely one of those games that
you know you might have to invest some
time into on a weekly basis and Tay and
I were actually talking about this right
before right before the stream I don't
know like it's good and it's good and
it's bad
so anthem I don't know anthem started
talking about their end game we're not a
hundred percent convinced that it's
there or it's gonna be there fast enough
mmm
oh I have to actually figure this out so
you have to actually assign it or you
don't have it let me make sure I
actually have it so the way that this
might work is if you want to play anthem
you're gonna buy that game play it it
seems like you're gonna be done with it
potentially by the time this comes out
and then play division and figure out if
that's your new endgame game and if it's
not anthem should come back around with
whatever there
game is you know in March mm-hmm
so I don't know it the timing works out
the money's not so great because you
might have to spend a lot of money on a
bunch of different games in a small
window uh anthem is actually not really
a wack knockoff of destiny it's more
like got some Bioware or sorry
it is Bioware obviously it's got some
Mass Effect's like multiplayer s
gameplay and then the loot system as
someone mentioned is pretty Diablo esque
but you could also argue that the vision
twos like loot system is very Diablo
because they even have set items and
you're basically doing what you would do
in Diablo as well which is your min
maxing roles on specific weapons and I'm
pretty sure I don't remember where I
heard this from but I think that even
the division devs they played a bunch of
Diablo and and drew inspirations from
from them as well which makes a lot of
sense with not only just asset Armour
but all the different you know weapons
you you get and or one of min/max to
have like what was what was the ones
back in the day I'm trying to think
about that everyone had in Division one
you always wanted like the like the god
perks and there was like three or four
like the vector yeah but yeah when the
vector was pretty ope you wanted to get
like the certain two perks and you would
just basically keep farming to roll
those two perks I'm sure a lot of that's
still in this game as well but to your
point I think that it'll be interesting
to see what anthem ends up looking like
endgame wise I know they sent out they
put out a video yesterday I was like
here's our end game but it's kind of the
stuff we know already
it feels very I don't know it feels very
aspirational on their part I think they
want to have an in-game but I'm not this
is just my personal opinion I'm not a
hundred percent dog yeah I mean if you
want to eat some dog I'm playing play
another game right now where you can you
can hunt like Elkins stuff or something
right bad guys eat the dogs
um is just like my personal take on it
but it feels like it's a bomber it feels
like anthem is a bit more get it out at
launch like I like I like what I've seen
so far it's it's completely mass effects
co-op in a bigger world which I love and
I love the javelins I love the flying
we'll see what they do at the end game
who knows if it's if it's they're not
and we also don't know how long the
campaign is like division has said
they're targeting 40 hours anthem I
don't know like if they're going for
they just do it on harder and harder
difficulty so I mean I do you know if
that 40 hours per campaign includes like
if you're going into like the dark zone
and stuff like that or is it just purely
like the single-player part of it that's
a good question so actually the game
shuttles you into the dark zone it'll
probably happen in this demo actually
okay so if I counts that but I mean it's
still part of like your progression
through the game right yeah the dark
zone is more of a part of division 2
than it was the first game and also it's
a lot more controlled so they've done a
lot of things they've done a lot of
things to make it friendly air 2 players
it's harder to go rogue and and you can
also do a stealth run in the dark zone
where you just break a bunch of chests
and steal a bunch of objectives and you
get a secret vendor at the end of that
rogue process as long as you don't get
killed
you could you could potentially not fire
a single shot go completely rogue and
get to the vendor so they're there now
stealth routes in the dark zone which is
I think that's good for solo players I
mean I think the only time it goes
really up to a player Ryan is when
you're doing a raid right because
they're gonna have raids they have said
Larry raids I think yeah they've
definitely said they're having raids we
haven't seen those yet I mean they're
but otherwise it's poor player right for
the most part assuming you want to group
up and things like that most of the
content
pre-raid is for players for players
right okay once you hit level 40 or
sorry once you hit the end camera things
level 30 which is the end of the game or
the end of the beginning of the game
that's confusing within games these days
then you you get into your
specializations which are the grenade
launcher the crossbow
and the sniper rifle the heavy sniper
rifle and and those are weapons that you
can use there their level balanced in
PvP modes and dark zones except for the
except for the one star zone nemesis
King I think it's gonna be tough for you
to potentially play on all show with
what you showed me in terms of your PC
specs but again I you know I haven't ran
a test off of your specs so I wouldn't
be sure but like to run an ultra I don't
know if that's enough
let's see Thank You Ryan for clearing
out the spam please please folks and
chat you know I think most of you guys
are being mostly folks are being pretty
good about it just please don't spam or
like try to promote your own channel
it's kind of rude we are playing like
you play yes what's just somewhere you
guys playing on a street oh my god we're
on a PC that has an i7 8700 K a 1070 gtx
1070 and like 32 gigs of ram that's most
of the important stuff you guys need to
know i'm using a gamepad though this
looks exactly like the first division
boring says Topher well you know there
were like I said they made a lot of
updates towards the end of the division
I feel like a lot of people didn't get
to experience that I know that they've
done other things to this game as well I
didn't even get to play it yet so I
don't know if you didn't like division 1
you're probably not gonna play this game
regardless right so but I think for the
folks that like the division and either
fell off or even kept continuing I think
there there's gonna be a good player
base for this as well and I know even I
had friends who are just more into the
military shooter
yeah the respect even though this isn't
like you know your pure military shooter
but it's more like how do I explain this
like contemporary setting you know just
yeah modern military guns and weapons
and and and look and feel it's not not
everybody's gonna be into you know
Destiny's future space aesthetic and
anthems also super sci-fi like a lot of
people just like rounded shooters yeah I
personally like the sci-fi feel like I
one of my biggest kind of like gripes
against the did
even though I know they say this is an
RPG type game is just like it's really
weird to me when I'm shooting a guy
that's just wearing street clothes and
he's like I'm shooting him in the face
and he's not dying right like that kind
of takes it away from me a little bit
but you know I also know it's a game you
know let's just and I played RPG game so
I know how that works it just feels
weird to me whereas you know her model
is nasty she she like definitely got
shot up in a gunfight in there showing I
cut up to showing the wear and tear on
her that's kind of Awesome and scary the
fact that we're even talking to somebody
though is already better than the first
game
what'd she pay with cans of beans cuz I
don't think money has any value right
now we take our payment yeah so like for
as I had mentioned for the for the folks
that are the the people I was talking
about that liked this game and did not
ever touch destiny it's because like you
know he owns guns and he goes the you
know gun range and so like for him he
identifies more with this and he enjoys
playing this and he would never touch a
game like destiny or an anthem you know
the bunch of people like that out there
as well I can't I can't deny like the
ammo sexual nature of this game you
definitely have a lot of customization
you get to mess with your weapons they
also did a great job of like when you
mess with your guns they actually now
give you the stat they give you the
stats on the side they probably do that
in the first game but I'm guessing they
they definitely overhauled and like
improve the UI I think you know quality
life wise this takes all the 1.8 stuff
mm-hmm
also under actually our editor did a
fantastic job and got a cache yeah you
earn cash is continuously to come I saw
um I saw one of the skills to is like
that you can upgrade down the road is
you can have it where you have a 50%
chance to get like one more item you
know cash which seems pretty good like
seems like a good maybe like beginning
skill just to really accelerate your
ability to get more items to kind of
like push through the grain game a
little bit faster it's a good early
investment in the game I have a ghost
that does that in destiny actually no
like 10% XP ghost so I'm always getting
them ever reversed Cash's Bruno I guess
in a very like base level like thinking
you can you can think of it as a non
sci-fi destiny it's not totally like
that obviously but if you want it if
that's how you want to go on a very like
basic level than yes sure
so check this out these guys are
actually patrolling from the settlement
which is cool like I said this is a bit
more like GTA san andreas where you
actually have factions patrolling the
map and you're actually fighting over a
little bit later in the game fighting
over control points to increase or
decrease the presence and power of those
factions which is cool that's cool
topher bringing up a good point just
kind of like talking about the games of
this week apex legends did drop earlier
this week and a lot of people also in
chat just having a fun time with that I
myself as well having a fun time you can
kill that right have you want me to hunt
it yeah do you get to get anything for
it meet you you get it you get a feeling
in all right well big game hunter your
big game hunter huh it was infected it
was gonna spread infection yeah steel
cleaner ideology I don't know like so
going back to that anthem conversation
do you think there's an end game day for
anthem yeah as it stands not really also
to the person that just that caz Dahlia
said no destiny is this this before
destiny and d1 beats destiny any day I'm
guessing the vision he's talking about
but technically destiny came out before
Division II but I I'm guessing he means
he'd rather play this game which is mix
that's fine but back to you anthem I
don't think as it stands not really
they're using the words right now like
the past couple days yes they've been
using the word endgame and they've been
releasing a bunch of different
information on what their endgame is
gonna look like they're saying
cataclysms and then you know of course
playing on difficulty a harder
difficulty and also bounties and things
like that yeah I mean most people know
what it is but like I just I don't know
we'll see I guess the the larger larger
question is do you want it to have an
end game is it a game for it's important
for you OOP well I think everyone had
thought that or I had thought that's
what that is but apparently who knows
I'm gonna start using my rollerball so
here's what I'm talking about with the
rollerball you can put it down and then
you have to actually tell it where to go
it used to just but then but then you
had no control of who you were having it
roll into though cuz sometimes you're
just like no no no I wish it like hit
the the bigger baddie you know these are
cool I mean I honestly think this is the
best pet in the game Bob Jones Aaron how
is the aiming and recoil with controller
good I prefer to play this game with a
controller of course you know if you
play on PC you get in the dark zone that
might be another issue so like I don't
know you can kind of mash the button and
try and get it to do what you want I got
a boss the same I've got a question from
Archie one big thing I saw in anthem is
the loop drop is bad is Division two
system better
um I think you you would probably get
like frequency of drops and like loot in
general I think Division two will
probably do better but again I'm basing
this off Division one and what I know
and then also basing it off of the
anthem beta that I played but there were
times within anthem I also got a lot of
loot so I don't know anthem had a good
amount of variety in weapons I actually
was pretty impressed with for now though
yeah I was pretty impressed with it like
there were definitely fusion rifles like
people play people play destiny there
were linear fusion rifles there were
SMGs from the coop from Mass Effect and
grenade launchers of like all different
types so they were grenade launchers
that were bouncing grenade launchers
there were it monster claws see like I
can't kill him kill him I can't get my
drone to like do what I wanted to do uh
uh well I mean I haven't tried so I
wouldn't know but it involves mashing a
lot of buttons it is our be in therapy
right like you just press our be over
there doing it it's weird I've that's
the one thing that I've found a bit
confusing about this game is both the
drones seem kind of unresponsive when
you try and get him to do things I'm not
positive on this but doesn't isn't there
like is there a way for you to mark him
with your like secret mine because I
feel like that's what I heard earlier
but I mean I guess I I wish I played a
little bit this morning but I didn't get
a chance to it's cool well test it we'll
test it for you on Street all right
let's keep going back here to chat but
yeah do you know what the DLC for
Division two is gonna be free they said
so FAR's confirmed that the first year
is okay include eyes from CJ I know
thank you for that I hesitate to use the
word free because you pay for a video
game and it's more like are you paying
for DLC and I think the first year is
included included it's probably the
right word to use bad see says much more
solid demo than the anthem one only
managed to connect twice for that one
really looking forward to this game yeah
I mean they definitely had connection
problems the first day but I would say
that's kind of their first attempt at
doing something to anthem scale-like
server wise whereas like you know
obviously division has done this in the
past and they have like a track record
for you know hosting a lot of people so
I mean I'm definitely happy that there's
no there's like less bugs with this than
anthem but I just want to also say like
you know base top expertise that's gonna
happen right anthem servers through the
the alpha and beta have been pretty
unstable like to a slightly concerning
degree we'll see if they get it worked
out like the 95 percent load bug that
first week was pretty bad it was a lot
better by day two of the VIP demo and
then they definitely made improvements
for the open beta but it's still I still
wouldn't call it
you know rock solid now I understand Kaz
de leus why you're such a big fan of the
division from what I can tell he
basically said I have mythic grade
schedule apex and division two to keep
up with so I can wait
so it sounds like you play Wow as well
and you know some of these gear options
and things like that kind of cater to
that or leaning into that so that's
awesome I like I think it's great I
think the set items is awesome yeah
because it gives you something to chase
it gives you something to like build
your character around I thought it was
really smart for set items to be honest
it also made things hard when you didn't
get what you wanted but you know if
anything
Diablo did a good job of helping you
with kanai's cube kind of like make
other set items if you just had extra
set items it was interesting that you
know people a lot of people said that
Diablo was kind of the thing everybody
should learn from in terms of loot how
they messed it up the first time and in
a bunch of other MMO was kind of messed
it up the same way it becomes like a
respective time thing and then like I
don't know yeah there are definitely
lessons to be learned but they they
eventually got it right and I mean I
think that's now helping other inform
other games of just like how that should
go but Wow has done it for a while and
wow is that a pretty good job with loot
as well but then unlike a bunch of other
games just repeated their mistakes wow
there's a lot of thank you for all the
questions
nemesis we are using a 1070 she's da da
da says I'm getting both anti man to
division to you but this game takes the
win I prefer the grounded movement and
getting to explore buildings and stuff
anthems world to them was met yeah I
mean I can totally understand that but
it's cool that you're gonna play both I
think if you have the opportunity to
play both and you wanna play both great
if you can only choose one and you want
to play the one you want that's also
fine you know like that's that's the
beauty of it if anything if you look at
February 15th as just a release date
that's in next week right
you have anthem early access or origin
subscribers right for PC and Xbox you
also have crackdown 3 you also have far
cry new dawn
you also have jump force and and you
have also Metro Exodus that's five games
five games next week that's a lot hype
and then you grind your Don and actually
I like that one a lot too nice and then
you have the Division two March 8th
right around the corner for those souls
fans you have SEC euro at the end of
March so there's a lot of games to play
I you know I'm half I'm just happy that
we have so many options you know pick
the one you want I'm blessed and Aaron's
blessed with the ability to kind of play
a lot of these games to try and play all
of them yeah but but we have the
opportunity to do some people don't even
have that chance right because they have
to make a decision right they have to
make a buyers decision of like well you
know there might be a person that has to
make that decision like oh do I play
anthem or do I play the division right
games are expensive and that's actually
one of the reasons why we would
definitely love to talk to you guys
about which one you're interested in cuz
we usually get the chance to sample all
of them and and we can help you get the
one that you actually want I will say
though for me personally growing up like
being able to get a game that you know
had a lot of replay value or just had a
lot of game to it like definitely saved
me money in the long run because I ended
up just staying home and playing games
instead of going out so I don't know
that's what wow did for me actually
let's see people make cry 5 demo is out
I think I've seen a couple people
mentioned that so there's that if you
guys are curious and want to try that
out that's out you can download it for
an hour actually I think video games are
one of the cheaper forms of
entertainment
I think of how much you pay for two
hours of a movie yeah bassy like as
mentioned all those games I did mention
there's so many good games in the first
quarter yeah you got Mortal Kombat as
well in April all right get out there
little buddy see like a cast alias is
still going to get cool he's playing an
anthem as well but also a while be a
phase is
main thing cool the only problem I have
with anthem is the controls for flying
of when you're using a mass keyboard I
agree with that Topher that's why I play
controller 100% that's why I play
controller because I really did not
personally like the flying on mouse
keyboard didn't feel good
also there's no which is actually weird
but so there's no PvP in that game so
you don't even have to worry about it
like that you could you could play Mouse
alright so I played gamepad in Division
two but you are eventually gonna run
into a dark zone issue where you might
need to go mouse and keyboard to keep up
actually it's funny a lot of us started
playing apex on a console because the PC
crabs just kind of insane yeah of course
you do you know if there's an open beta
pretty division team I don't know I'd
have to look it up okay let me look that
up in a second cuz some people were
asking so seems like there's that the
husbands of anthem vent hey again like I
I think it's it's fine and healthy to
have an open discussion you know like if
you like one game or the other that's
fine I would just say like going like
just because you like one game and
someone likes another game doesn't mean
that like you have to like I'm not
saying anyone in chat is doing this no
but I'm just saying you guys don't have
to attack each other because you like a
certain game there's all kinds people in
this world that like all kinds of
different things which is kind of good i
Nathan since I got bored with the anthem
this demo has me wanting the whole game
now I haven't played enough of this one
Nathan but I'll you know that's a fair
point but it was countered by Carlos
that said anthem demo is boring what
question mark I thought I had fun with
anthem but you know there was only it's
only a slice of the game right so get I
kind of got tired of that stronghold
because that's all I was doing at some
point just to get the higher tier loot
and stuff like that
so at some point like demos are gonna go
only take me so far I haven't played
this one yet and I do want to check this
out what I did play division and I liked
the loot in division I'm a very min max
loot chaser and that is technically in
anthem as well but I know what I'm
getting in the division in terms of like
what loot I'm trying to seek trying to
get like set armors really building your
class a different way it's cool you know
that you know they have the dart zone as
well which is a PVE pvp there also
skirmish which when I did see skirmish
it did look a little boring when I watch
gameplay but I don't know how it is to
play it it's it's definitely the least
interesting thing at launch oh my god
the dark zones are a bit more
interesting there's only three maps at
launch and it's okay like I I wouldn't
def I definitely not pick it over
crucible in destiny or just doing other
activities in this game however if you
do need to grind out some gear you get
caches from playing it so it might be a
good you need to knock out some some
objectives or just get a little bit more
XP yeah glory boy geo saying apex will
die in a month actually I don't think
I'll dine a month
I do wish that these like their only
reason why I say that is because the
season pass will be out by then I think
I kind of wish they released the battle
pass sorry I called the season pass I
meant battle pass I wish they released
the battle pass like this Monday when
they released the game but it's coming
in March so I think the battle pass will
kind of reinvigorate people to play but
I am worried about the longevity of Apex
but we'll see it's still the number one
game like on Twitch and things like that
so that just shows you know its
potential promise but again it's based
on how long that that holds but for
tonight is also delaying I think their
season by like two weeks or something so
you know apex definitely has like this
window here for like a month almost at
least to kind of keep getting more
players on so yeah
they also spread out their battle paths
so that it's not right away which might
that might have been intentional so that
they hold on to their audience a bit bit
longer give them a bit more to do yeah
but I think their battle passes last
like twelve months so like I don't know
kind of wish it was like sooner maybe
not like this week you could maybe like
get players in and then play next week I
don't know um let's see oh yeah Carlos I
will take a look and try to find out
about open beta sorry about that
okay I'll check that in a second Joseph
this is not PvP right now this is just
us going through I think story
our mission yeah this is this is the
beginning of the game and then tomorrow
they're gonna actually let you unlock
portions of the endgame the endgame is
where the black tusk faction it's a new
faction and game faction they invade the
map and then make everything a lot
harder and they also make your
specializations a lot more needed so I
think they're gonna if it's like the
demo they're gonna give you a
specialization to mess around with I
went around to get that guy in his crit
spot in his butt spot and he's now
facing me you know what's interesting
actually so they don't seem to take any
damage until you break their armor which
conceptually that makes a lot of sense
it's kind of cool actually so once you
break their armor then they become
pretty vulnerable see at least this kind
of makes sense of why he's a bullet
sponge
yeah he's wearing armor I feel like his
arms his arms open now so now look at ya
all right so okay so I can respect that
so that makes a lot more does it more
yeah so whereas like in the bass past at
at best the guy had you know he had
maybe a best you know what I mean where
you're like all right dude that doesn't
make sense
where's at least here you can you can
see the armor falling off right and I'm
like okay now my bullet should be doing
a lot what she did there so I can
appreciate that let me look up to see if
there's open mid oh I have one sliver of
health and no health back side need to
play this careful for a sec because I
don't for some reason I thought that was
your arm where I don't think I can take
another bullet and then I can go pick up
whatever that dude had some sick drops
so you do have to actually unlock your
attachment slots through the skills menu
which is I don't know like it's it's a
small inconvenience it's a little bit
unnecessary kind of wish he just picked
up attachments and you were good alright
here we get work schedules down there to
check out with this dude head oh you got
your health back there we go hey rafter
let's yeah do that
please Thank You Gajan so just have
those two guns but you start upgrading
your mass right away you can also we
found that inventory ran out pretty
quick so you should definitely be what
marking your stuff is junk as quickly as
possible I'm checking on the oak if
there's an open bit or not Kenyan cool
let's get some grenades back Jeremy
Garcia that is kind of how this game
works I'm guessing you haven't played
too much of the original division but it
is a cover based shooter you can't be
yeah I would say part of it the reason
why it looks more just straightforward
cover based shooting right now it's just
because we're early on in the game the
only thing he really has is a seeker
mine as you get farther into the game
you get other abilities you will
eventually be a specialist you'll have
other kind of like a special ability and
then you're not even really seeing like
the the teamwork and the class stuff yet
really come into play and then there's
also just different guns and I don't
know that's that is what this game is
though yeah
there's also now a whole another level
of modding on top of those weapons not
just not just the attachments but
there's there's more modding than that
but on your abilities you can mod those
you can mod your special weapon I
wouldn't compare apex to this at all we
were just having a conversation but I do
see some people in chat just comparing
games I don't think it's reasonable or
fair but you know apex you guys do what
you want to do I mean you can learn
something from every game apex has are
really that ping system was really good
this is good you got a turret yeah
minigun time umm apex is ping systems
really good in like any game could learn
from that yeah I agree
and then also group apex also has a
really good easy yelling at me that's
just amazing
they've a really good pickup system so
when you look at items on the ground
because that few was get off yep yep
apex is pickup system is really good too
like
you look at items on the ground it does
a good job of telling you what they are
and if they're better than what you have
currently I finish
yeah the and also as caz Daley's
mentioned the skill tree for this game
is pretty complex as well so it's worth
noting I didn't you just turret that
thing I did I did you're nyama the
health the health wasn't actually fully
indicating what it was a box night so
you'd like do it do a drone there you go
there yeah
whoa I like it the physics watch out for
that gasoline don't want to be near that
good points I was a oftentimes by the
time that drone got around to doing what
I wanted to do is just faster to shoot
them it's a good lead off a rat turtle
rabbit apex came out at a perfect time
dot that dot
I can't tell us sarcasm may probably
sarcasm I think it's fine
I think it might be tough come next week
but I think people I don't think that
all people that are playing apex are
necessarily all gonna play anthem but
you know or bar crying you dawn or metro
or you know but hey I think a point that
you guys don't understand I understand
what you guys are understating though is
that you you have to realize that apex
legends too even though this is a
Division two term apex Legends is a like
full-fledged game it's not like a we're
still working on it situation that's my
subtle jab at like fortnight which like
I'm like how are you not a game
yeah fortnight is not early access know
that game is done and they've been
changing it like just what did why can't
they just say the game is out like why
why keep the early access they're like
what is it what is it I don't know I'm
gonna get back to talking about the
division to that game is early access
like god of wars early access like it's
done that game knows what it is already
I do like the the world here looks nice
I just like that there's people in it
this time the first game was just set in
a place where everybody had already died
and that just wasn't
there's no way to get invested in that
did you catch it some folks and they
give you a baseball hat sometimes just
get that bit the hot base beanie all
those beige beanies you just collected
that we know there's probably beige
beanies in here more for tonight chefs I
mean they're okay I'll jab it for a
night for some of the things I think
that aren't great but I do like I think
it's not to be understated that they are
doing something like interesting and
they're they're handling things the
right way and caz I think as somebody
that plays well yourself you can
appreciate a lot of the things that for
Knights doing right for tonight builds
buzz around their seasons they
constantly have things happening to the
world where people are like oh oh my god
like yesterday there was like
earthquakes or something and they get
hype around the next season right which
is kind of what WoW is really great for
they would set up their next expansion
by having something happen in their
world to kind of start reflecting what
was coming right and that's that's
something I have to say for tonight as
well pleasure to meet you the idea of
keeping one map fresh the way that
four-night has done it is genius
honestly like I'm bored of a lot of
other classic franchises that I've been
playing for a long time and I think for
tonight's to certain extent still
holding my attention because just
interesting how they are evolving the
game they're almost like dungeon
mastering that game I think all right
another thing I'm going to say about
just division in general is that there's
gonna be a lot of people here that are
gonna keep saying this is just like
division 1 this is division 1 you have
to realize as a sequel they're gonna
take the best part I am helping just not
the way you want me to we need you out
there again your leg wouldn't stop you
it's not about that I know it isn't but
if we fail oh right
oh right
we can probably spare some people
I'll be outside
she said you did your part
I won't forget it
[Music]
okay so yeah so like there is no way
that division 2 is not going to have
some semblance of division 1 so like I
think it's crazy that everyone's like go
to like on trying to hate on a game is
like oh it's just like that other game
no of course it is it's a sequel it's a
sequel like the hope is that they take
everything they learned and every update
that they did and use that to make a
better second game a better sequel and
time will tell
I like what I'm seeing so far but time
will tell
yes Kaz they do have that continuity
assuming you're talking about what I was
talking about
I mean sometimes sequels reinvent games
but in this case the type of game that
this is it just needed to be a lot
better than what it was the first time
around
shady nodes so you do have to go back to
the White House
to get your skills unlocked you keep
that to the main base of operations
right yeah you can't do it currently at
the like the smaller checkpoint areas
yeah safe houses and yes safe houses are
still a thing it's fine you can fast
travel to him I'm ok with it
it's a safe house is here this is a
control point so these are what the
factions fight over it's gonna go back
to the White House real quick and has
gills upgrade them skills
it's interesting it the map alright it
seems they've really talked about the
size too much it seems not too much
bigger okay then the first game but the
dark zones are split up okay so we can
okay so here's where you can screw up
some of these points here are shared so
you need to unlock the skill another
skill slot and then so here's what
you're talking about today we're field
proficiency cash if you invest in this
early on you get more cashes over time
I like this element to the game the mod
stuff I agree with you a little bit
that's kind of a little overkill but
like I like the perk stuff the perk
stuff makes sense to me because it's
like cool I get to pick one of these and
it will potentially influence how how my
game goes for the next little bit right
like it's almost like you know this is
gonna happen it's gonna be like which
skills are best to level early I don't
know if that's gonna have like
necessarily impact how you play your
game but it might like there might be
some skills there that you're probably
like oh do I really need that right now
it'll I mean it seems like the kind of
pain that only happens in the first hour
of a game first hour - and then you'll
probably never think about it again but
I don't know I would rather just pick up
attachments and use them I think you
wrecked ship did invest multiple points
into attachments to get certain ones
unlocked box Knight not sure if I'm
gonna be streaming jump force next week
there's just so many games next week so
what to see I can't guarantee that ones
but maybe the week after I don't know
we'll see I definitely am interested
just because you know I'm an anime boy
and that game is basically anime
fanservice up the wazoo so we're gonna
go ahead and head over to a control
point these are where the factions fight
on the map and you can actually I could
just got a flare gun so I can call in a
friendly faction to help me with it and
then we can head over to one of the main
missions the world that looks real nice
and that you know the first game was
like that too it was just a real good
looking world which is I think Ruby does
worlds it's one of their like best best
things that they do like if you played
while
is just gorgeous q and on I would say
the graphics look good to me
but you know obviously anything that's
in a stream that you're watching back is
not ever gonna look like what the game
looks like you know if you're playing in
person
I actually think it looks pretty good
like as the Aaron even just said the
world looks cool in my opinion but you
know that's just me it's my opinion and
take it with a grain of salt so I think
I just earned a cache actually get good
level up indicators and also if you're
playing with your friends you see when
they level up which is kind of cool
there's a whiff city happening over
there
ooh
you get flanked a lot in this game too
this game loves to spawn people behind
you
yeah keeps you on your toes it has a lot
of a monster closets just people people
hiding in closets waiting to fight you
dr. Jorge's says the division to the
return of witches I really hope there
isn't glitches well would I be shocked
if someone found some down the road
maybe probably not but I hope that you
can't do incursions and just like hit a
tank from above which we did oh yeah use
the barricade shield to go through a
wall yeah you got to think that they
like learn from that and like hopefully
even got some of those people in his QA
testers or something girl boost dead
yeah it's dead now two bullets are you
definitely have bullets well I have
health back though and take a grenade
uh yeah in the first game I would sorry
is crossing fossa in the first game you
would frequently at least in the dark
zone just run out of bullets trying to
take people down
you were very spongy nemesis thanks for
the kind words Aaron here over there and
I'm Eric hello and thank you for tuning
in to GameSpot life we go live Monday
through Friday 11:00 a.m. Pacific
Standard Time unless for some reason we
can play some stuff early in that case
we we sometimes show up early so we have
a cash as well Stu dildo shotgun just
because we got one kind of open a cash
so you get cash gets those items glasses
is Eric that's that's fair got got our
vector well you guys back there yes we
go vector
although vectors never quite have enough
bullets that's always the shotgun man
that's fine that's always the vector
ways to not have quite enough bullets so
you know all the mod slots are there you
do have to unlock them this time around
and we got we got a better mask we got
we got a better backpack haven't picked
up any beige beanies yet that's also
true Patrick brings up a good point this
is the start of game I know they said
why do they why do people expect
everything to be god-awful hard
third division gets a lot harder down
the road especially like incursions and
things like that
it gets pretty nasty that's when it kind
of maybe gets a little bit bullet
spongier actually but yeah until you
like get proper gear and stuff like that
some of the later and gamey stuff is is
definitely quite a bit more difficulty
or difficult also at the end of the main
game when the black tusk faction invades
they're a lot tougher you need your
specialized weapons to take them on also
if you're curious what that end game
looks like that's tomorrow but we also
have footage of the black dust faction I
believe on our YouTube gameplay channel
and also on gamespot.com is that correct
I believe so we do pretty sure put it up
plus a preview with a bunch of that
stuff in it yeah so if you want to see
what that looks like you can you know
check that out or you know maybe we'll
stream tomorrow I'm not sure on that
note yet
only because our community Friday boys
are back Ben and John Luke they'll be
back tomorrow because I believe tonight
geralt of rivia is gonna make his way in
a monitor in a world which means they're
gonna do Monster Hunter World Friday's
tomorrow but you never know you might
see me and Aaron back tomorrow to do
another division stream but this time
with specialists as well as some of that
endgame content I had that up somewhere
let me tell you exactly what that is it
is invaded and invaded mission and then
the specializations as I had mentioned
starts tomorrow 8:00 a.m. Pacific
Standard Time the black tusk faction at
the end of the game they just invade all
of your other missions and they are a
lot harder oh so that's how they're
making those missions harder yeah sure
okay that's one of the ways they're I
think there's some randomized elements
okay but it's mostly the blast black
tusk faction just invading I cannot so
the minigun is a big problem in this one
you got to get through it so yeah these
are control points and then once you
take them you also get some pretty good
loot out of it what if I can get up here
without getting minions guys they're
gangster lean oh you are crazy your one
shot do you regen any health at all mmm
medium bro see if I can go drone well
this is getting sticky yeah yeah I would
not say that this is easy um for the
earlier comment it's definitely the way
that your health is regenerating or not
and it can shut though this particularly
the way people always spawn behind you
that's one of the things in this game
that just makes everything a lot more
difficult so there's my friendly faction
finally coming in you know I shot that
flare earlier so they're gonna help us
out no Bob Jones they are not aliens the
black test faction that
that's coming from down there all right
although if I'm being honest okay at
least he got on the turret I guess but
he ran by a dude that was shooting you
that oh what is that guy doing he's an
ice skating man ice skating time uh from
behind nope nope nope nope nope oh come
rescue me oh they can actually revive
you maybe we'll find out call for backup
let's see what that does
I feel like I would be shocked if this
guy could save you but you never know
that probably are these all the people
who shot me
I was shot by three separate people um I
was playing with other people at the
event so I don't know if I can get
revived by families I'm assuming he said
hey brother I saw you playing I saw you
play the Hong Kong massacre and you
totally sold me on it what a great game
and good job with your quick learning
skills oh thanks you know what is funny
about that I actually wish I slow mode
because you can style way more with slow
mo and I didn't really mess around with
that till after so glad you played the
game Jeffrey and I hope you slow mode
because it's actually quite the the
mechanics pretty fun for those of you
that don't know how Cong massacre came
out was it last month it's kind of like
a mix between hotline Miami with the
like the slow mo of Max Payne it's
pretty fun game it's on Steam I think
was like on sale at one point for 18
bucks or something like that a fun game
but we are playing currently playing the
private beta for the division 2 going
through some of the story beats right
now going back to stop a control point
which is without action yeah cool my
control bros did not show up in time to
help me they let me down not gonna lie
happens mr. mica gaming says yeah this
is a pure looter shooter right up my
alley
awesome have fun megatronics installing
that beta right now hope you enjoy it if
you you can't really play the division
so I don't the mistake I made there's
you can't play it aggressively if you
punch in two levels too deeply there
tend to be a lot of monster closets
where people just wait and then the
just open up when you get past them and
they kill you oh they don't always spawn
on the same level necessarily tree rocks
but I mean I get your point that they
spawn a bunch behind you which is can be
annoying I think almost all the levels
that we played if you if you punched
past the entry part of the room you
usually got flanked or there was usually
a spawn behind you
we're like midway through a room it me
see II says how much bigger is the map
in the game compared to the first game
so this is the beta map we haven't seen
gaps we haven't seen beyond this okay
but these are the three dark zones here
island they're 27 to 30 there seems to
be a landmark here and then there seems
to be an island so this is what we've
seen so far I don't know if it goes
beyond this okay it seems like that's
the map that seems sizeable I it doesn't
seem massive they actually used lidar
they went over DC and try to recreate it
as they said as much of a one-to-one
scale as they could
Patrick's Fitzsimmons if I took his word
for it says the map is 20% bigger 20%
bigger that's what he's saying but I
don't know that for facts so oh let's
see it's bigger and you know is bigger
more meaningful that's another you yeah
yeah we got is that one of those it is
playing for like a hour yeah that's a
known bug then they're working on
there's like a fax kind of thing this is
the equivalent of when the Kinect used
to tell you to take a break
said you you've been playing too much
video games or get up and get some water
go take a break you guys remember that
if anybody else played Kinect we're
playing on we are playing on PC Randy
Division 1 was the worst game I've
bought in a while yeah what didn't you
like about it
you you know if you didn't like Division
one you probably will not like Division
two because its oh there's queues that's
hot
oh man it's okay it looks like it's
going fast this is this is like when me
and Joey stream overwatch events and
then the first day is usually a crap
show and we just get stuck in queues
what's up just frame deep how are you
doing
welcome back familiar face to be fair
this is way better than the anthem
loading screen that we had to stream for
two or three hours that's true that was
the first day though they've mostly
fixed that by like Sunday Saturday night
Sunday totally yeah
Megatron says February 22nd anthem comes
out hype technically 15th if you have
the origin access projects so I guess
these are we actually didn't mess around
with these too much in the preview event
so I can donate donate or steal oh my
goodness I donate my steely resolve I am
I just
I don't actually even know what this is
we didn't see this before I am donating
my excess loot so that I can't sell it
but I'm getting something
see blueprint okay so this is the to
start unlocking blueprints nice quiz
kill I hope you enjoy division 2 once it
comes out I hope you're able to play
that private beta interesting so what
you guys are gonna see in the settlement
itself is actually more than it's more
than what we saw at the preview event
you sell them all my crap but you got
them in division books yeah you gotta
mark it as junk and then tell your junk
questions that's the best that's the
best way to unload a bunch of it
we did we did fill up yeah whiskey yeah
origin access is only Xbox and PC so if
you're waiting for anthem on PlayStation
fortunately it's like a what
semi-exclusive time to exclusive origin
has been hinting that they might go to
ps4 or my good a ps4 Heather the origin
access my go-to ps4
michael says anthems demo
had bugs that aren't in the full game
the past July and were very transparent
yeah I agree with that I mean they were
open through the process and definitely
work through it I mean it's just I think
everyone on the Internet's gonna be
upset and like you know when they can't
play their game especially when you're
like a VI like when you call it a VIP
demo and you're struggling to get in and
kind of feels bad right if they call it
a private beta or something maybe you
don't feel as upset I don't know
they should have just called it now for
that was that was on on par with an
alpha did the anthem won it was
definitely not demo quality you're gonna
have to or Patrick says you have to
unlock PvP we know thank you
it comes off I believe the second
mission in here once you get through
that I'll send you over to the dark zone
so hit the control point one more time
then we'll go do a mission beef indicate
asking or saying and asking he they said
so far I feel like I'm looking at the
division one with new updated mechanics
and missions I see kind of similar
graphics or the weapons the same is the
is is just the same overall it feels
like there's more tweaking that you can
do with the weapons but a vector still
feels like a vector I mean again this
seems like they took the best of the 1.8
Update and a lot of that went into the
sequel although I would argue that the
world is better because there's people
in it this time was really not into the
everybody's already dead storyline from
before alright let's see if we can take
this outpost you know I think I just
pushed in too far too quick which is
again the design of this game doesn't
really want you to do that got a ticket
nice and slow you know I'm gonna work
work the left side nope he just went
right right at me alright let's get a
grenade on you buddy
you need a grenade everybody gets a
grenade huh didn't work yeah you don't
you can't throw that far I hear a lot of
melee people whoa rear spawns alright
what the G alright this has gone wall
they all spawn
behind me and now they're chasing me see
this is cool they had a helmet I like
that dictum Oh
get rekt this is the part of division I
didn't look at all the people that shot
me this is the that's cool that's new
we'll go into a mission I would actually
did this with other people before some
of the design and divisions a little
scummy like when you get rushed by a ton
of high-level do's with ton of armor
like that not not super into that
because what can you do like unless you
take your friends with you I think that
while depending on the situation like
obviously when you don't know what
you're dealing with it's tougher so like
the first time was gonna be rough but
you know if you did that again in theory
and you knew where these enemies were
coming from you can prepare for it we
can plan for it I mean the thing about
division if you think about it once
people really figured out spawn points
for incursions and things like that they
were basically farming them as they were
coming out it's like once you get used
to it you're like okay I know the two
big dudes are gonna come out of this
door people are sending up turrets
people are like you know what I mean
like they're totally ready for them it's
just the the first time maybe the second
time you go through it depending on the
angles you're taking you don't expect
certain things to come out so it and I
do agree in some cases that it feels a
little cheap but hey I I kind of like
that to some degree like to have that
difficulty I guess it is kind of
frustrating you know but I do I do enjoy
the fact that they're there I don't know
maybe it's like a cheap challenge and
some people's mind but you know I did
deal with stuff right there's definitely
satisfaction in getting good at
something like failing the first time
and then learning the pattern Joseph is
not an open beta it's a private beta I
think as Kyle as mentioned you have to
play it you you must have pre-ordered it
but it is technically on ps4 because we
could have selected ps4 as a option
but yeah localized matter a whole new
game too much to do was playing it
earlier this morning I mean if what
Aaron says is true for D our campaign
ish aiming for like that's gonna be a
while as if they're telling us little
board to it to be honest
those two factions person on a personal
level though personal level I'm looking
forward more to anthem than Division two
but I'm definitely gonna play both which
one are you looking forward more to so
you kind of mentioned this earlier but
we're lucky to so you know be able to
play these games at work and so I think
it's gonna work out great I like the
world of anthem simply because I love
sci-fi and I love Mass Effect and
honestly it's a it to me it's just Mass
Effect co-op in a bigger world which is
amazing but I don't think there's an end
game in place yet so I think what what's
gonna happen is we're gonna be able to
play both because I think we're gonna be
able to play anthem for a month and then
I think it's gonna be done after that
well they're gonna have March updates
don't know it'll be done for the month
of that division is max baby you're not
gonna get those masterworks and all that
craziness that's that's where this game
gets to to right where you're getting
set armor you're trying to get like the
best version of one gun you're trying to
get cooldown bonuses or bonuses to like
ice damage fire damage lightning damage
I don't know that stuff is like the
stuff that gets me like excited that's
why both games are definitely getting it
gonna be games I go after and play but
just from a like world
maybe not world but I just like to sight
the sci-fi aesthetic more but that
doesn't mean I'm not gonna have fun
getting the loots in this game as well
I'm a looter shooter too so definitely
I'm a looter in general Diablo wow just
give me the good loot lineage yeah
anyways so you brought up a good point
actually which is you know mid maxing in
anthem is actually gonna be pretty
interesting the primer combo system is a
little complex in a way that is
fun to learn it's a new thing you know
that we that we don't know and that's
always it was a bit more fun to learn a
new thing that is to to master something
that you're familiar with and in that
regard yet the combo primer system mmm
is really interesting anthem and each
javelin interacts with detonating a
primer differently which is really cool
yeah under Johnson says I'm getting
maxed out as soon as possible and anthem
yeah I will - I mean I'm just curious
like how frequent or how often like you
know you're getting some of this better
loot or like how we make it you know how
randomized it is I guess because from
what I can tell with like master work
stuff like they do have kind of some
intrinsic perks but it's like in terms
of like it's doing something different
like I think one of them was like when
you reload it will detonate a combo
which is interesting because you
definitely have to be in the fray up in
the fray for that but otherwise it's
like here are four stats on a gun and
hopefully you get it someone asked is
this gun Gale online no unfortunately I
can't be a badass like Kirito and like
run around the pistol and a lightsaber
and like cut bullets anyways wow you go
down fast in this game if you're not
using the cover system right that is
well again that's something you can
change down the road you can make
yourself a beefy a beefy boy or girl
depending on your armor system stuff
yeah that's true actually the high
stamina and whatnot the armor sets are
when did the armor sets really take off
in division cuz there I forget which
update it was it came a little later but
it definitely was a thing that people
were striving for because it changed how
you played the game right it made
certain builds or certain abilities more
potent like you know you'd have a person
running like fool like was a tech or
skill or whatever so that they could
just like almost like spam abilities in
a way yeah and you almost wanted to have
at least one of those on your team and
then they could and then like it would
enhance your ultimate abilities as well
so I like that aspect of this game and
those armor sets are definitely gonna be
a huge part of
of this game Tim the only thing I've
seen so far in this beta that would
resemble your question about like if the
tougher PvE opponents are less of a
bullet sponge they're still spongy but
at least when I saw the boss he had like
let's say a full plate of armor right or
a full set of armor on like and I mean I
don't know like metal armor so you
actually had to work your way through
their armor to then actually deal proper
damage to them and once Aaron kind of
shed that armor Aaron could shoot him in
the arm and he took significant damage
so I think they've addressed it by like
giving some of these bigger bosses you
know actual like viewable armor I guess
it just conceptually it feels a lot
better to have bosses that you have to
break their armor for them to actually
take any damage yeah and I mean even
some of these nope nope nope nope even
some of the like oh okay even some of
the weaker opponents here that that he's
fighting against they have helmets right
like the melee the melee charging
enemies have helmets so if you shoot
them in the helmets you see the dink
right so it's like you want to shoot
somewhere else and when you do you know
then they're dead
I see they playing on Xbox one we're not
actually we're playing on PC with a
controller but if you want to leave
because we're on Xbox one that's fine
clearly your must be a PC or Playstation
fan we are on PC egg chin I mean this
game is definitely better with friends
or probably random matchmaking
it's definitely tougher solo well also
not to knock you here but you're using
just an SMG in these like like what I
would think an assault rifle would do
better but I don't know I don't even
know hit that much matters because like
if this was like Cod SMG rules
everything so
you also get charged quite a lot in this
game so honestly pushing up is really a
bad idea
unless you have like this map is
designed for at least three people to be
pushing one person pushing each side see
you see he had a well Aaron shredded it
but he did have a helmet she did have a
helmet rather that's cuz I have a vector
I mean yeah people died I mean the game
is not easy for those that were saying
it's easy I guess I mean it's definitely
you need to work your tactics as Aaron
mentioned pushing up they're too far up
basically costing him his life whereas
now he's playing a little slower smarter
right right
pushing up is a bad idea in this game I
mean I I don't feel confident pushing up
until like I have some of that better
gear and you know you can kind of absorb
some of that damage and not worry so
much or you know you just need other
players alongside you who can you can
make up for a bad move or at least cover
you know everybody pushes the lane at
the same time let's get my nades back up
yeah this would also be a good time for
me to go back and get my second ability
because having the turrets really
helpful when you're playing solo yeah
what's been the hardest part of the game
so far as a solo player probably just
not knowing the spawns and then finding
I mean I'm speaking for and I live here
and speak in a second about it but from
what I've seen it's it's pretty much
like maybe being in poor positioning and
then getting like overloaded by other
spawns that like you don't see happening
like that seems to be the hardest part
of the game that I can see I don't know
what are your thoughts are not
regenerating health I don't think I am
regenerating haven't seen you but I
don't know if that's like a perk thing
you need down the road could be because
there was definitely a med pack perk and
I don't know if it was like hey if you
take this perk you get another like
health pack that you can use which seems
also pretty clutch if that is something
you can level up that's something I
probably be like taking maybe earlier
just so I knew that I had you know three
heals potentially whoa you get flanked a
lot in this game and without other
people helping you out
it's problem yeah just as egg change
says just always watch your six you know
and check that rate that map I guess in
the top left corner as much as possible
I mean if you guys saw me try and take
that control point earlier I initiated
the control point and immediately had a
pack of guys spawn behind me how could
you put hours into it if it's a beta oh
that's pretty easy I can imagine because
one you're going through a couple main
missions there's five additional side
missions there's also control points and
activities as Aaron was doing and on top
of that there's dark zone and there's
skirmish PvP which is more of a
traditional PvP so you could easily put
hours into this beta you could
definitely just end up in the dark zone
playing against other players does they
have any cute outfits I'm sure they're
wool right now it's randomized I haven't
unlocked any outfits yet the first one I
would say they'll fit outfits were a bit
bland in the first game and I haven't
seen anything crazy yet to indicate that
there's a lot more customization
visually in this game Wayne as much as
you are not a fan of EA there's no way
I'm not gonna get anthem to play it also
technically apex Legends is an EA game
and that seems to be pretty
well-received right now all the marco
transactions around that game for the
most part are cosmetic you can
technically earn the other characters it
just takes a little bit of time but
you're not I don't think you're
necessarily losing out by not having the
other characters let's meet each other I
get it I mean I let's spare want to make
that comment EA has you know like
they've stumbled a bit in the past and
oh they've big straight murdered a
couple of franchises and there's been a
graveyard
perhaps I was it you know one of the
things that apex legends had a bunch of
people who left titanfall worried about
was whether that was the end of
titanfall it's just apex legends and
that was it it now looks like they're
working on another titanfall game we
don't know what that's gonna be but uh
there's some valid concerns there but if
you you know if you support a franchise
or a developer and the publisher is just
the ones putting up the money Nicholas
Wimberly says have they said if there is
character customization similar to
wildlands I saw so the only thing that
was open and this was there was a
randomized customization yeah you said
you mentioned there's like more
wildlands esque tattoos and clothing so
it seems like there is there so there's
probably some blending of those elements
are aspects who is this where you got to
hold this spot I think this might just
be the end of it but usually but good to
see you back way no super 90 that's Auto
shotgun me or is it Sam I am I will
there be open betas as the I will try so
far from what I can tell I haven't seen
one thing about that I've been trying to
ask around the rest of our news team and
things like that but they also kind of
like haven't seen anything about that so
I fortunately I don't then I know who's
the publisher for apex I mean the
publisher is a right and the developer
is respawn yeah it sounds like respawn
when ta with it after they were mostly
done okay we made this you're gonna use
that and be good with it I'm sure EA was
happy to have it because you know
everybody wants a battle royale these
days battle Royales all the all the rage
no those are worse fire storms that I
mean that's also in March actually the
battlefield battle royale see how that
goes
it could I don't know it could
potentially do better than the base game
base games kind of I don't okay so great
Fox says I think a destiny division
style Halo game would be cool then
Sagittarius said we're getting that
already its anthem I don't think that's
true the shooting and anthem is very
different than what you would experience
in a Halo or a destiny if there was a
game that had those kind of shooting
mechanics with the kind of like gameplay
elements of a division or you know
destiny I would play the crap out of
that because to me destiny like in the
current like day I think is still one of
the best feeling shooters just their
design around their guns like sound of
the guns the weight of the guns the feel
of the guns you know when somebody
shoots you with a thorn or a last word
you know they're shooting you with the
last word and that's like one of the
things I think even around the office
like even if people don't necessarily
play destiny anymore or or whatnot
that's the one thing they can kind of
like be like well I know that it's still
one of the most solid shooters out there
feeling wise and like sound lines it's
hard to be first-person yeah first
person versus third person to is another
very good point
like you know anthem and division are
both third-person
what anthem is going for it is the
flight and combo system but you're gonna
have a hard time beating just how good
it feels to shoot a gun in the game like
destiny space guns do you really want
that dough gray fox teehee saying that
keep it halo just have it follow the
game of the service model I don't know
man
most people are not fond of the games of
service model but it's kind of a weird
that's kind of a weird double thing
because they want to play their games
forever now oh we have to hold to heal
to now it's not even like an instant I
was just looking and I'm so used to the
old one which is like you just hit a
button and like part of your health
comes back I like that actually
so like the industry I feel like the
industry needs to step back from the
edge a little bit when it comes to
destiny came up with this thing where
you're just supposed to play every game
forever and I don't think that's good
for the industry like I'd meet that that
just stifles other games from being made
if you're just expected to support
something indefinitely so I don't know
not every game has to be games a service
some games are good that way but there's
plenty game I don't know like this is
where you you and I Tate feel a little
bit differently which is if anthem just
ends up being a really sick campaign and
I'd be happy to put it down after a
month and just say man that was fun I
really enjoyed that I don't necessarily
know if I need anthem to be a games of
service from everything they've shown
like I I mean they're gonna have a
campaign obviously but I don't have no
idea how long that's gonna last
you know is do it do it but harder I get
enough hook and we'll see you did you
know they said they're gonna have
cataclysms and we don't know what that
is yet it me see to me I left third
person a hell of a lot more than first
person I can't really do first person
all that well filled third person games
just play better yeah I don't know like
I maybe I'm just like growing up I
played more first person than third
person and so like when I started you
know playing division and some other
third person games it was kind of a
little weird for me and I don't know I
just played too much counter-strike
going up or something down into that
meat locker forever it's fine
stay stay frosty frosty yeah stay frosty
I got a look of all those bad mr. freeze
Batman
Hans Arnold Schwarzenegger puns they're
really bad I need Ben Ben Ben knows them
all any comment on anthem review date no
I mean especially if we're
you know no I'm gonna skanking myself
safe no yeah cool teat says I'm building
my first PC just for this that's awesome
I hope you enjoy it
yeah yeah I've actually so like no man I
haven't really liked live-streamed on my
own in a long time mainly because I know
that I'm we're streaming like once a day
or Monday to Friday here but like now
that I'm on my like fiance's teaching
schedule like she wakes up and leaves
that the like the house by 6:30 like I
might do like early ass morning streams
again especially with games like anthem
and stuff coming out and division are
you gonna be the first one in the office
to get jars breath I don't know I think
that's just luck of the draw right oh
here's a big boy okay so he's fully
plated in armor as you can see I don't
know if you can see it that well but
yeah but here's also the thing I don't
have any health and I don't have any
health packs you have grenades and this
may just be a wipe
was there no like loot box before this
room cuz usually aren't there like boxes
with like almost every big room they
like let you you mean I can make it I
think it's I don't know if it's still
there but nope nope yep nope nope how is
he shooting up through there because
that's how strong they are in the gym
I'm calling shenanigans on that one
honestly like this is more fun not so no
no so turn back yeah yeah yeah there you
go
maybe you used a lot of it before oh it
doesn't restock your health though okay
I mean also I didn't take my second
skill skill yet and I need that I
probably need the turret after this if I
get a skill point I thought you were
going back to the main thing just now
I chose unlocking attachment which I
don't currently possess oh haha at Delta
3 there was an agent coming in though
you've been Delta 3 did you see that do
you think you start them you have to
start the mission over we're gonna find
out cuz we just got Delta 3 is Wow dead
no it never dies
the only thing that was ever gonna kill
Wow was if Titan ever came out and that
didn't come out so I don't I mean
there's definitely less players playing
well but Wow well it's probably still
there's probably still a few million at
least I would imagine still playing the
game but er says the only way of making
the game harder was to remove health
regen yeah I mean that's one of those
things where when you're by yourself I
mean again Tay you mention this but as
you get later on you can probably throw
down your your health drone your health
station I mean you're not this is it's
more of an RPG and some things you're
just not gonna be able to do until you
have the right loadout which is kind of
the game that it is alright we got back
in I think that you know you know I have
95 one thing really cool about anthem
was when you got kicked out like this
it resumed where you were when you came
back into the game which was interesting
that was a good yeah I think you know
this already but just in case beef into
cake says protip whole day to transfer
between cover to cover yeah and you'll
you'll have a damage or an you'll have a
damage reduction yeah I think that was
that was from d1 right or Division one
yeah it was cover to cover that's why we
actually asked the developers why there
wasn't a Crouch and they kind of want
you to just engage in their cover system
so let me see if I have a scale point
because I'm gonna need I need my second
ability that's fair
we'll probably got that second ability
do that mission and then use mostly wrap
up one less there's something newer
whatever to try out or do yeah that
sounds good jiron so are they we need
this
give me that let's just faster out we're
really quick we're definitely cool
coming back tomorrow though and doing
the endgame content uh we'll see I
cannot confirm or deny that we'll see
you Friday because they're definitely
streaming tomorrow and we'd have to
stream around that so I just don't want
to promise anyone did anything to the
stream with a chat but we could
potentially either before them or
something but we'd have to come in early
ITM that's a really good point
third-person lets you see your character
which honestly is really cool when you
have a game of
customization and first you know destiny
it's it's you never really get to see
yourself unless you're in your your
actual customization menu which is not
quite as interesting okay now we have
better better stuff okay and dashes okay
let's go back real quick and give this
another shot and then I think we're good
so welcome endless stream tomorrow cron
don't worry I was there would there was
never gonna be like a take there's a way
kind of thing so so we can hit a safe
house a control point or go back we
could do a side mission you don't hit a
side mission you do whatever you want
the world is your oyster let's do that
Eric just streaming tomorrow morning
Sonia I'm not probably not coming into
the office that early yeah that would
make my day crazy long beta invites were
sent out CDR via email dark road we
definitely haven't reviewed this game so
I don't know why you're putting that in
there and please don't do that can't
review a game that's not out that's
correct
hello dragon fire we ran into some
pretty crazy Auto shotguns it me see
probably like about half an hour I think
Aaron's got a dentist's appointment
yeh dentist time I love you guys oh
thank you that's very nice of you to say
so we're gonna go pick up a quick side
mission
DC does look good no no these guys are
all fight each other they're all
factions
they're all being reared to one another
Nicholson I think that the UI is
definitely upgraded from the previous
game the map style is similar the
stories you know different you know it
has to be the graphics I didn't play on
PC so hard for me to compare and the
bullets fun so far this stuff hasn't
really seen that spongy to me it seems a
lot more right now but i but endgame is
really where it felt spongy though so
what do I know
did you get your second ability I did
cool so this should be known as I don't
really know who thinks grenade spam is a
great thing you're supposed to dodge it
grenade spam is not fun you see that guy
died and the noise with him was a shield
he's like the failings of the division
so a good tip to you can actually just
destruct your abilities and they'll come
back a bit faster uh kamal hello how do
the weapon and armor stats compared to
division I'm guessing while a lot more
variety for sure and the weapon sets
that you know we were debating about
when those actually kind of fully came
into their own in Division one
but weapon sets are all there and
they're gonna be a much bigger thing
this time around there's different enemy
factions from previous or from division
one there are and they also fight over
the map which is really cool they it's a
lot more a lot more the world's a lot
more in motion at any given time and you
fight over control points to sort of
control those territories mystery little
boy asking is this vastly different or
the first game I don't think it's vastly
different I don't so no I don't think so
I mean there will be differences but I
don't think it's vastly different now
with that but I guess maybe I can't say
that because I haven't played through
the game for d1 but you know it's
obviously a sequel and
even as their invention it's taking a
lot of what was good in 1.8 right yeah
taking that stuff learning that lesson
making sure that into and then all the
other minor tweaks to it like the world
has more people as Erin mentioned and
you know you'll see other layers there's
a new PvP like skirmish mode new endgame
faction when you're done dark zone will
work a little bit different as well will
there be a single-player campaign yeah
we're going through some of it right now
Joe and honestly the single-player
campaign just having people you can talk
to this time around makes a big
difference like you know last time
around everybody was already dead by the
time you got got there and that just it
just wasn't that I don't know
wasn't it compelling knowing that you
know anybody you're trying to help has
already passed its then why are you
really trying to help them oh let's see
so yeah Jeff if you yeah if you're not
into if you weren't into the first game
you're right in that you're probably not
going to like this one
you had beef in the cases if you had to
sell this game to us with just
highlighting one aspect of division 2
what would that be
what is this game's strongest selling
point I mean wouldn't what people really
liked about the division at least the
first game was that you could just go a
lot deeper on the weapon systems and
there's just armor and armor yeah
there's just a lot more play than a game
like destiny it's and also like I don't
know what other RPG shooters are out
there there's it was really just destiny
for a long time and then you know anthem
is you anthem is coming out but you
don't have a ton of options
all right let me try to get like a nice
little sentence here if you want a third
person shoot third person co-op shooter
that has a deep and complex loot and
gear system with skill based abilities
that has endgame local content as well
as a 40-hour story campaign or a four
yard campaign then you should try the
division - did that work that's that
seemed like a really long one sentence
to get there in time yeah
that also has PvP / PvP PvE it's just a
much deeper style of shooter than what
you would get in another I think one of
the one things I'm under selling if I'm
trying to sell anything - is that one of
the bigger additions would be the a
player raids which they I don't think
they've talked too much about yet but
that was definitely not in the first
game and that to me for some of the more
hardcore division players it's gonna be
potentially really cool because in the
past you're just kind of doing
incursions and kind of doing dark zone
as like the end and you know but now you
have something to kind of work for that
you need the hire like it's just like
what Wow kind of did right you have like
a story and you're going through the
story and you have missions once you get
through the missions and even along the
way - like fully leveling out you are
doing dungeons and then those dungeons
you can still do after and then those
dungeons then kind of like feed into
like if you want to do the raid then you
know cool like do these dungeons to gear
up for the raid right so I guess
question is how much of your life do you
want to invest into shooter if you're
looking super casual then stick with you
know your competitive pvps if you're
looking for shooters with how casual
the competitive PvP though I mean
defense I guess are you talking about
time right they're talking about casual
in terms of time not a casual in terms
of like play black ops for I think is a
good example of something you could do
nightly and just really enjoy yourself
you know as long as like there's not
kids yelling at me about how I I'm not
very good at the game or something
that's that's where you turn off voice
chat that's the first rule of all
multiplayer games is you turn off voice
like game oh there was health back there
if you need it but then games like I
think if it even apex legends as an
example because that's kind of what we
I've been playing a little bit of more
this week I feel like even though they
do a great job with a ping system I feel
like it's still pretty imperative to
have somebody that's like kind of
shocked calling and there are people
that actually play and aren't there to
like troll or whatever they want to win
you know I I definitely respect and
appreciate those people helping kind of
like a lead a team to hopefully victory
you know a lot of HUD in the game I
don't like it says Jim Carrey
well my bill turn it off actually you
don't like the HUD UI or the HUD then
you're probably not like gonna like the
HUD and the anthem anthem actually had
also some pretty good settings to turn
those off yeah but I'm just saying I
hate how I have to like do everything at
the forge and I can't like see or change
anything like in my build at all until
like Coast or pre mission we'll see what
their social space does to that because
they do but that means nothing you're
still in a space that like if I'm out in
the world doing something and I happen
to pick up a new piece of loot I cannot
just use it right away see or use it
right away yeah like why man maybe
that's something they can change and
maybe particularly a free room hey I
hear what you're saying it's it's way
better to just be able to swish it's
like if you found a gold here or purple
you're like cool I found a purple like I
might need it right now I might need to
use it
if I was a betting man you know how long
it takes to actually get to your loadout
even when you're in the tower I would
I'm Melinda beds frostbite
frostbites not have not made for RPGs
frostbites made for battlefield like
frostbite wasn't able to handle a mass
affects new system yes Simone I think
some of the assignments are I saw Simon
Simone uh I think a lot of chat even
kind of like brought up a good point
it's like if you got a year's worth of
gameplay before having to pay for more
like I don't think there's much to be
worried about I think if you were
thinking about playing the game and you
maybe enjoy the first one I don't see
how you're not probably playing from day
one I mean if you want to wait for a
sale or something that's totally up to
you which is also a smart move but I
feel like if you're getting a year's
worth of potential like extra content
like I think that's it feels very reason
I think like if you made it through the
whole year and you're still playing
you're probably like yeah like I want to
play more you know like you don't have
to play more obviously but if you had
the ability and you want to you know
potentially spend more money I don't
even know what that looks like down the
road because they haven't really said
anything like that's up to you if you
want to keep playing or if you think
like cool I got my fix I'm done you know
there's a guy who's got aggressive
yes I keep getting messages incoming
backup requests and also you know I like
honestly I wonder if the agent messages
are other people Oh feet Thank You
turret buddy you telling me he's already
behind me um I do wonder if maybe that's
other people in the map going down like
asking for help
those are control points too so I'm
gonna just go up here and hit that
control point again give him a little
buddy behind to take care of things we
haven't quite explored yet how do you
just Rando group up with other people
but honestly this game is you're
probably gonna have a bit of a better
time if you do group up okay alright
question is all right let's try what's
good Ken Scott how are you doing let's
try doing this differently so the minute
I fired last time he immediately knew
what was up so let's let's sneak attack
Uncle Sam's devil Rainbow six siege
remains Ubisoft's at best work I mean
they've definitely done a great job
supporting that game continuing to like
you know support and really support the
community as well so it's definitely one
of their stronger titles for sure I see
is that game was like Patriots right for
the longest time yeah I got converted
over from Patriots whoa see like who
likes grenades BAM
I don't like grenade spam I don't know
why that's a mechanic hey get over here
buddy so you don't like constantly just
like fight camp one spot you know keep
you moving so I think there's a spawner
over here that's what I mean last time
but we'll see how later dental max nice
tough life
and your face buddy
oh this bones right there nope nope no I
don't like getting stuck to cover in
this game it's one thing I like I I'm
not somebody plays cover based shooters
regularly and I do find that I often get
stuck to cover unintentionally when I'm
trying to escape or do things my job my
stuff on it where is it where's my team
where's my team at they're away
grenades BAM why is grenade spam
mechanic remember the pro tip earlier
from beefcake if you can and I know it's
tough because like in the moment you
don't want to do it but you can ate a
whole day too and then you'll get some
protection to that other cover spot
which is good you oh there's grenade bro
whoa okay so my team is finally showing
up
glad to help finally showed up tanks
here sort of thing
nope no nope nope seed like nah I didn't
want to stick to that I was trying to go
like into the left but did you hit the
whatever the button is to go to cover
though if you hit a I was trying to roll
so like I was trying to do a roll to the
right roll stuck you do the stuck me
there where I got shot in the back so
that's I don't know like I'm I still
wish division would just let me crouch
and do some things that I can't
currently do so I think calling for
backup
might send a message to your friends
like your actual friends see it's like
respawn point these respond of brutal
man they're uh they're not super close
well you never know like part of it was
even on the map like you just have to
find the safe houses on the map and it
could just be like yeah even what's here
you just don't have as many of those
access points right now I don't think
you can play this game offline
I would really doubt that I don't think
so either
Qi not for Honor's at ub game I can
tolerate they've also done a lot of like
good updates and things like that James
that's probably not playing for honor
tomorrow unfortunately we're gonna do
some community Friday's tomorrow where
we're gonna play some Geralt of Rivia
who's making his way to Monster Hunter
world which is cool crossover so John we
can Ben will be heading that up you
might see me and Aaron back tomorrow for
division end game possibly not too sure
yet can't commit to that because I all I
honestly feel like even though it'll
probably match make like depending on
how hard that stuff is like I just you
know I have concerns I guess we could
definitely test out matchmaking today
and see I think there might be like a
decent random matchmaking system in here
too but other people in the office also
have some codes you definitely need to
work together because if the endgame
stuff is hard these bad guys real
aggressive also by tomorrow I should
have mods unlocked which make your
weapons a lot more deadly wine fire is
actually pretty effective in this game
yeah I was always pretty good at um in
the first game as well what's up
converse still at it yep okay last try
on this control point so I want the left
route but then this game does grenades
BAM right so there's really no safe
route which is why I think it's this
game is probably just more about gear
and having people does this area tell
you like hey you should be this level or
have this level gear or is it like a
because I'm guessing if it's red arrow
actually no that's not true because the
stuff was around your level right well
of are you right now 3 yeah I like
office for right so it's not like
honestly your yearly might just need a
level might just need some friends or or
like oh they're already are they still
attacking it
there's just regulars oh there are two
factions oh that's my dude
those were my dudes no longer they died
don't get created that's a that's a good
tip yeah it's kind of hard not to so I
can't call in my friend so maybe they
are still fighting certain that craps
out you're done yeah I mean like that's
how those games work it's gonna be the
same for anthem same for division same
for Diablo same for a while like it's
not like the division is the or division
two rather is the only game that is like
online only or whatever yeah there's the
enemy leader so actually it didn't start
me from scratch do I have grenades let's
just let's just throw a lot of grenades
I thought you don't like grenades man
though well I like it when I do it this
guy there we go all right got a blue
worth that's how I look at it I look at
worth based on the color of the item
maximum effort generally I like purple
but you know when you're only living
that green life oh you got a chest a
blue chest a SC s quarter harness get
out of here yeah you're not gonna hold
it by yourself so then once you once you
take it there's also a later Jeff no
stop sorry it's not done yet I forgot
there's a part two part two is I you
know you got to hold it Ryan says do
enemy still magically know where you are
in this one yeah pretty much
I feel like yes because my example would
be that there's that one time Aaron was
trying to run out of the like to get to
what we thought there would be supplies
for and like the moment he left cover
they just all like well I guess moved I
mean he did leave cover so I guess
technically they should see him but like
they immediately fired upon him whoo
let's go supply room and so if you take
control points you get a supply room
which obviously it's gonna have a lot of
lot of stuff you want let's go this is
what I'm talking about the loot life
when you only live in that green life
yeah man that's like so so you first
started off in grey like white calm in
life and then you're like oh I'm moving
up to green life and then you're like oh
I'm starting to see the blue life and
then purple life and then gold life and
then after you hit gold life it's like
what perks are on those gold things oh
and green there's technically the other
green life which is um which is the set
items set armors like hey does it have
its claws in you already that has plus
ten percent fire rate I bet his green
one doesn't have that yeah where's my I
swear I think I'm locked maybe somethin
picked him up yet but I did unlock Mac
and do a magazine me it says view all
weapon wants so I do have a plus 25 so
anyway I have my magazine mod already
you have a blue chest as well I think
yeah so okay so heavy breather so I got
two heavy breathers like you can already
start messing with this I think in the
beta so this this 810 armor all you need
SMGs though ooh
crit hit damage is always good you got
15% seeker skill so yeah you know like
you can see how you start climbing the
ladder pretty fast
no caches yeah what's the exclamation in
your backpack or is that just the skill
that they're trying to like get you to
use this is it's not as good maybe
they're just indicating oh you just have
new stuff I think and that's before you
start chunking everything but yes that's
the one thing I will say that I can at
least appreciate from a UI they had an
in Division one but like the like the
ability to junk a bunch of stuff is
amazing like you don't understand how
crappy it is to break things down one at
a time like having the ability to like
be like all of this stuff is trash well
now trash there was at one point you
reply using it but
trash and then getting to a vendor and
just hitting one button and having it
all go away yep just don't mistakenly
get rid of the wrong thing I've
definitely done that you you got to try
to like lock out your good stuff wasn't
that a bug in the first game where if
you were hovering over something you
liked while you'd said delete junk you
accidentally would delete your favorite
weapon that I don't remember because I
don't had that didn't happen to me per
se but definitely they like the me
junking something on accident definitely
happened because it was you know when
you're crafting and you're crafting like
nine vectors there's probably one vector
you really like and you're like that's
my best role that I've made but like
I've also just like because like in my
haste because I have eight other vectors
I'm trying to get rid of that I'm like
oh [ __ ] I just got rid of my vector that
I actually rolled that was like decent I
was like oh well can you still do
jumping jacks yes oh yeah you can what's
this this is a another just kind of
pointed Oh get out of my face is it
another control point it's a point of
interest this is not a full control
point so there's also question marks
around the map and those question marks
lead you to places I think there's
definitely quality of life upgrades
rasma day and before that guy hit me in
the face of the bat rudely I was trying
to remember so I don't think lockout I
don't think you could lock here at the
launch of the first division and that
was an issue I think they eventually had
it but I'm not I can't remember I'd let
chat help me without with that one I
guess reboot the console I almost feel
like this should be a little bit more
like destiny when you're in the open
world they probably should just match
and row people yeah people see have
mentioned that to how like the only way
you see other agents is in the dark zone
and you don't see them like while you're
just playing through this but actually
now that I think about it I think the
reason why you don't see other agents is
because I think everything that you see
in front of you is scaling towards you
so it would be weird to then have
someone that's like 8 or 7 in your area
because
what is the what is what is being scaled
your level their level I think that's
part of the reason why now that I think
about it so they already have a level
what is that gold is that a google
access key as much as I wanted it to
have getting excited about the fact that
that could be a yellow item
I think it's literally as they said that
it's a access key dang it
huh sotae to your point they actually
already have a level balancing system in
this game that is active in the dark
zone and PvP so actually it wouldn't be
that hard for them to level balanced
diamonds a we are looking at chat hello
what do I do next that's totally fair
sugeun Sagan's again I'm is equal to so
I'm solo now at least I'm getting help
although they didn't revive me actually
I might prefer that I feel like they're
more of a distraction than they are more
of like real help I haven't really seen
them like take it any enemy out and I
feel like at least they're there to like
bullet sponge for you are you doing
what's the COG on the map I'm trying to
figure what that is there's like a cog
right here I don't know you picked up an
access key maybe um I don't know the
maps indicating there's something there
I'm just not sure what it is these guys
are doing some work they're not useless
Wow yeah I told you they're bullet
sponges they're basically like the
frontline that's getting killed while
you hopefully clean them all up that's
how I look at it your cannon fodder yeah
maybe you just have to clear that out
before you can do the clog yeah the
cogwheel was the broadcast restored
mission
go forth cannon fodder what time's your
appointment I gotta check out latest
1:30
I'm keep going until then then okay all
right
safe house go check out a safe house
safe houses are I think you have to take
them now
there's a little bit different let's go
see what's at the safe house so yeah it
seems like farming those control points
up front will get you the best gear
initially so if you're going solo you
know we found that mission well to be
fair we were doing all right and then we
got a kicked out you know what that
could be a problem if you're playing
this and that mission can be can take
you awhile solo and if you get booted
from the beta the middle of it and
that's problem we are currently playing
the division two private beta probably
gone for another 15 to 30 minutes
depending on what what we got going on
but thank you guys all for tuning in
guys and gals
everyone has bokes to the Fancy Pants
VIP demo from anthem yeah but then they
had an open demo though so that's sort
of more than not well played and down
I gotta release it people are very nice
putting all these bungee cords around
the mat for us is this worth
pre-ordering or play I think that's hard
for me to answer because I don't know
what type of games you enjoy' did you
enjoy the division you know I think if
you enjoyed the division you'll probably
enjoy this one if you didn't and you've
never played the division I'd say maybe
check out the division I'm sure it's on
like some super crazy sale
and then see if you enjoyed that type of
gameplay and if you do and it's probably
worth pre-order guess what you when you
want exactly how do your pre-orders what
would you like to play when is the open
demo I haven't heard of one
I'm still trying to investigate but what
I've heard is there might not be one but
I'll try to fact-check some more I just
don't want to definitively say that
we're currently in private beta though
saving private beta that's very good how
do you get into the dark zone just go to
that part of the map right it's after a
mission if you play through the main
missions and the demo it'll force you
into the dark side it'll it'll introduce
you to the darks in the game as far as I
know doesn't Lee just walking anymore
you have to actually okay
did somebody join my game right after we
were talking about how that should be a
thing I mean is kernel black not a is
that that looks like an agent right
yeah he's level five - no no maybe
people do randomly joined now I mean you
always solve people in safe houses
though like right now
true yeah but you were outside but maybe
it's just like around the safehouse area
that you see because you could kind of
see people back in the day - because you
could do some of those like I don't know
if you guys remember from division one
but we used to farm that one what was it
the King guy at the top of the map you
just kept loading into that safe zone
and people would just kill that guy get
the loot and then like do it again over
and over and over again cuz he was like
an easy farm that just kept showing up
so here's your matchmaking station
doesn't look like this is all
interesting there's a salvage like so
you need to clear your inventory
interesting and yeah definitely player
so yeah you're right you know what he so
this is I think this is also part of the
system of getting your faction stronger
on certain parts of the map you have a
new skill unlock as well you gotta go
all the way back to the White House for
skills
I don't know how I feel about that no
that's not true guys do you know how I
feel about that you should not have to
go back to the White House to didn't
mess with your skills it should just be
anywhere or like at least a safe house
okay so we can hit a question mark we
can hit another control point I remember
this one that one's hard because it is
defending yourself in all directions so
he's he'll probably vanish letter beep
into the cake they're stopping by
you're probably banished as soon as we
leave this area I think you're right we
are in Washington DC Caleb no longer in
New York yep takes place seven months
later obviously the virus was not
contained and Washington DC has some
issues you know he's still there I don't
know see what happens here's a control
point is he still in existence yeah I
don't know I guess we're in the same
game now could be area base as well but
i haven't played as much jesus you have
so it's a little different to you
because you played in a more controlled
environment yeah we played locally in
like a match made in Virant hey guys
hurt that's trying to hit him with my
drone get out there little buddy
pretty sure the president's dead nope
you just let your cell phone yeah I did
that that was nice when took a hit too
you will see that stutter here in a
second there's definitely some stutter
please your cover-to-cover suggestion
yeah get into performance reps yeah I
don't know I don't know if that's likely
in the sea or actual game though nope
okay guys oh it is like laggy is it cuz
it might be because I'm in Colonel
Black's game I don't I honestly don't
know how I don't know how Colonel black
got into my game whoa colonel is it
lacking for you yeah what there's a
colonel in our game and our performance
has tanked a bit it's probably not great
if other people joining you tanks your
performance we're not sure if that's why
though so I can't really confirm or deny
if that's like latency or so it's beta
that's what I'll say is a blanket
statement man you are aggressive cannon
fodder
hey alright I am willing to bet it's
breaking the game yeah I guess we are I
don't know how I'm willing to bet it's
cuz somebody joined us you all need a
new GPU we have a 1070 so I'm pretty
sure egg chin that it's not the GPU and
everything leading up to this point was
totally fine
so I don't know what changed in this
area I think what change was somebody
joined our someone joined our game I'm
honestly not entirely sure how that
person joined us or like where that
happened well I thought like in the past
I've definitely like done certain areas
with people before I could've sworn you
are reaching three hours network syncing
clients possibly it's not just your PC
now it is definitely not we're
definitely seeing it and feeling it the
same way you are except it might be
worse on your end because you're
watching via stream instead of me
watching in a real-time chug who would
that rat ran away though okay now it's
okay nope
he's gonna wreck it I would get on that
turret but I'm afraid of what would
happen with the performance
Wow what is that with these transcripts
I don't know to be honest it's happening
to us in real time so I honestly don't
know is that the boss it is the boss the
leader all right little buddy
go get them names just one pass be
smarter okay yeah yeah
oh god I'm falling into the world you
recovered got him nailed it like
Scarface still shooting you cleared it
good job all right let's go find the
cash before I fall through the world
no there's edition yeah I guess I don't
know can you unlock it you got it looks
like a 1930 slideshow yeah it's uh it's
it's everything you're seeing we're
seeing here and I don't I honestly got
trying to aim do you not know how to
tell you why that's the case I'm like
ready to like just have a crash to be
honest didn't they recommend I'll have
to go look at the tweet but they might
have actually recommended a full
computer restart after you've been
playing for three hours really you
should get on the tweeters I am on their
Twitter let's see which gets the Rev
grenades because I don't have to aim of
those for accessing data those four band
people
I mean on the bright side being
underground as a kid cover all guys go
to the forums to see some known issues
except that page what I'm trying to
revive this cabbage doesn't even work ok
so we are aware of issues causing
players gamesclient to crash on xbox and
pc after extended gameplay session while
ps4 players may experience performance
degradation after three plus hours of
uninterrupted gameplay to circumvent
both issues we recommend players restart
their game client every two to three
hours yeah beta oh that's a big boy it's
a beta get some yeah
does he not shoot them he only looks
like he's targeting you which is an
interesting thing here I don't know how
I feel about that got him you know he's
dead he's got to be so dead I just
there's the player oh man the
performance definitely tank when that
dude showed up in our game let's go to
the supply room get some guns oh yeah
it's my favorite loadout in this game is
an m60 with the side of M 62 m 60s just
fire continuously minutes no man the
sniper rifles were the meta towards the
end of D 1 man those things did the most
damage
Marty out of inventory space yeah
because you haven't broke anything I
watched you go to the station I'm like
oh he's not gonna break anything alright
I guess you must be fine I didn't want
to bore people on stream yeah but you
have the super junk system you could
have just went you could have actually
trashed all of it other than the stuff
you you have equipped I will pick up one
more thing cuz now you can still do the
junk system from here though if you had
to just mark alright maybe that's not
the most entertaining thing to show show
the people thanks for the subscription
egg chin
we do stream often we stream every
Monday to Friday unless there's a
holiday at 11 a.m. Pacific Standard Time
we'll be back tomorrow with community
Fridays
monster hunter world with a little
Geralt of Rivia in there and then we may
or may not be back for more division in
action cuz they're gonna have endgame
content tomorrow
so one m60 to go it says Ryan yeah
pretty much
so can I do all my junk no I can't I can
mark junk but I can't I'm pretty sure if
you continue to mark other junk it
should all be there but if you don't
want to take that risk
you just deconstruct it now nope well
there's all my Parts I think I have to
go back to based on Ida to actually
finish the junking process you can
deconstruct it with right stick yeah but
it only doesn't one at a time no that
should do all your junk does it not do
all your junk no not here I think you
can do that back at base which is a
scrap all junk I mean you could do it at
the safe house too right you saw it at
the safe house well go try it oh yeah
it's a junk station damn you guys still
streaming says Rob yeah I guess so
that's the thing yeah we are probably
for like five more minutes I've to ten
more minutes only because I don't want
to see another one of those like frame
drop issue things although it seems fine
now that kernels not in here so I have
no idea well like I actually don't know
how kernel got in our game I don't know
if well okay and I think we're done I
think we're done unless you want to
restart the game because this is not
gonna go away I promise you that like if
you want to restart the client I will
I'm totally down for you to restart the
client but at this point I definitely
don't want to keep screaming like
massive like degradation of gameplay so
I'm gonna go full camera what do we
stream photo mode do you really want to
shrink photo yeah what do you want to do
right Aaron did you open up oh quit out
okay I'm gonna go camera here if it lets
me quit alt f4 it that's what I would do
oh man I think I'm just gonna have to
die don't worry you're hearing the game
but you're gonna reload the game because
I feel like we have encountered some
beta
gameplay degradation and instead of
having you guys have to suffer through
watching that because it's it's painful
for me to watch here I'm gonna have
Aaron like get out of the game and then
we'll come back so this it is beta
though so you know and they have been
pretty apparent open about how some of
that stuff could happen it even says the
restarted every two three hours so we'll
try that I almost want to like just test
it just to see by closing it and kind of
like restarting I think they said
restart the whole clients let's try this
it says restart game client I'm gonna
log in again all that for it makes you
faster I know right I know an alt tab
makes you jump higher to verification
codes that's the thing now yep
Ben I'm on it I actually read that same
thing as part of their FAQ so I'm sure
that's where we kind of I'm really
curious I want to dig into how that
other guy got into our game because I'm
curious if that was just in the world or
if that was a mistake or like Jaden
maybe do you do encounter people now
more frequently in the world but we're
like maybe we walked out of the safe
house and he he or she like didn't get a
separate instance and that's why the
game started going wonky Leah blue I
can't give you an informed answer in
terms of my opinion of this game cuz I
haven't played it I'm looking forward to
playing it but so far it feels like a
very strong division game I mean
honestly if you like the first one and
you were looking for more that's exactly
what this is so far
this guy I'm 1 as Ryan point out I'm 1
m60 away from my favorite loadout which
is the loadout in which you can
continuously fire for a one minute or
two minutes straight but extended mags
on those things you're good to go
she's never stopped I don't believe in
the m60 life there was never an m60 meta
as far as I'm concerned it's it's all
about how long you can shoot for just
like 200 rounds in each one going from
one of the next yeah but what why why do
that when you can use another gun that
within 5 shots will do probably as much
as the entire magazine in a faster time
entertainment because everybody around
me thinks the game's broken because of
just how long I've been shooting with it
a little bit little bit griefing alright
so we own this control point
oh it's control point needs stuff yeah
you need beans water and screws does
that mean I'll lose it if I don't give
you those things who knows well what I
want to know is I want like to see you
do something and see like oh that like
you know restarting the client actually
fixed our issue because that we have hit
around the two-hour mark now that seems
good before it was freezing when I just
wanted even yeah but there were enemies
but I'm assuming that if you can kind of
do that then it's fine well go find
something to shoot this was part of
their FAQ for this beta so it is a known
thing so if you do have any type of
gameplay degradation they say to restart
every two or three hours be aware of
that oh cool underground we did not see
this before
slaw what score are you guys giving this
won't know until it comes out it's so
far away yeah so many other games coming
out before this game so no I have no
score for you
I mean anthem is out next week only for
origin access though yeah that's like 15
how's the performance on the GTX Andy no
I do you not know because we only have a
1070 that was big no it's not gonna let
us go in the sewer well I think sad to
the map I think is just content that
they don't want you to access right now
yeah I wouldn't be surprised if there's
like an incursion or something down
there speed of Underground I am
surprised they didn't take some of their
better DLCs like the survival DLC was
excellent and underground random done
hey we're back huh it's fixed us bloated
talking trash about my m60 and dating
facts oh I just did a loop okay where
was I headed I was headed to this thing
but it had me going that's how the
internet works chosen one you give them
the space to discuss a beta and usually
you uh you know usually you'll get a lot
of people bashing it that's how it goes
this is where I say like that's this is
why we can't have nice things
so if you want to go the dark zone
you're playing this beta just go finish
the main missions and it'll it'll spit
you out in a dark zone we'd have to turn
on the FPS counter pc peasants gaming
for me to tell you
one thing I don't know I always thought
there should be a stealth build in this
game particularly for the dark zone
how would that work
I mean if you're running around solo a
lot of times you just get smoked so what
are what what in this game if you were
to make a stealth character for the dark
zone what what would you what properties
would you give this agent that are fair
and balanced and pretty much the ability
to run away that's what you need is the
ability to get away but does that but
does that one boost one is that only a
solo thing or is this like a gear set
that anyone can use because it had nicly
has to be anyone that could use it which
then means the PV peers will use that
speed boost as well to murder as you
yeah now you can make the argument that
maybe if it's when you get shot but I
feel like either that is definitely in
another game or I feel like is that in
Division one
yeah a speed no Michael Hardy has been
lurking this entire time he comes out to
say a stealth wood stealth build would
completely make the dark zone pointless
well there's now a stealth running on
the dark zone there's a thievery run
where you get thievery and that's how
you beat it we could start a mission and
I don't fully know time to finish it but
I could definitely start one yeah I
don't know I mean like worst case is if
you're like Midway I'll just try to wrap
it up cool let's do that now there get
somebody who doesn't have a cloak right
no that would be so broken cloaking
would be so broken could you imagine if
someone cloaked and came up to you and
shotgun to you know I don't know the
first game I just got killed by God to
your people on a regular basis well
that's because they have full like load
outs like they have full sets of like
probably the best static armors and then
they also have like full sets of like
probably the best like perks on a weapon
so they're gonna shred you like and to
be fair actually it's it's different in
this game now it's yeah they even
changed it towards the end of division
one when they was like 1.8 like they
changed how manhunt works and stuff like
that the the dark zones this time around
are our level balanced just telling me
to go here where are you telling me to
go trying to remember where the entrance
is and around the corner
Paul from what I've seen for the menu UI
looks good to me it looks like tweaked
and maybe slightly upgraded from
previous iteration but this is just me
viewing it so how is this any different
gameplay from the first game it's not
really just sequel for a reason they're
not gonna take too many steps to change
how the gameplay works there isn't a
player raid there is a new PvP that's
like more of a just skirmish mode
instead of a dark zone trying to try to
like think of other things Mike more
Mike's got some fans there that's cool
in the chat I'm relatively sure that was
the entrance so let me see building your
ruins hey guys today I didn't you still
feel like bullet sponges uh yes and no
from what I've seen so far early yes in
the sense that like they still take a
lot of damage but no in the sense that
at least it's more apparent like okay
they have full like a full rig of armor
that you have to like blast off but once
you blast off that armor they are no
longer like bullet sponges so at least
it makes more sense that they can take
the damage that they can because like
you see the big boss he has like a full
set armor and you're blowing that on
wear off and then once that armor goes
off you shred them it makes a difference
like conceptually it's it's a little bit
better yeah that you have to take off
the armor first so I don't know if those
the entrance to the grand Washington
hotels should be right where I was let
me see if I can get it to trigger again
if they see a lot more stuff going on on
this map
get my I'm sixty out dang
Wow a play arrays like destiny destiny
is only a six play rid they've never had
more than six all right bro serious if
in the division two if they'll have like
what Wow has essentially which is they
would have two iterations of a raid
which is you know you have I think you
hold X there to matchmake right yeah and
I'm gonna get where they had like kind
of easier raid and then the harder raid
but the easier raid had like lesser
tiered well it had the same leap with
the loot wasn't as good as if you did
like the harder version whatever I think
what's going on is it actually wanted to
direct us to you know I probably should
get a safehouse
thing this is the one that we did you
know wants us to do Jefferson Trade
Center that's why I wouldn't just open
right away so once you beat it then it
allows you to matchmake back into it
that's what it is that's why that door
didn't open for us that's interesting so
yeah it's like the first game you walk
up to it you're completed it says yeah
well you can do it from the menu
probably like the first game shoot
Pinkins
not a lot of paint yeah there's only two
missions right now the grand Washington
hotel would you finish and then with
Jefferson Jefferson Trade Center so
after you beat I believe the second one
then it should just go right to opening
up the dark zone for you so there should
be it doesn't just end there there's a
look there's more to do and honestly if
you want a PvP in the dark zone that
could probably last you the rest of this
beta I mean there's so more stuff
tomorrow as well lettered Jenna demo max
peace out that guy had a bad day
so it's interesting I wonder if we could
have match made in the first time we can
try that of course I haven't turned off
voice chat so I can't guarantee what
people will say does the environment
graphics look any better or worse than
the video one I'm gonna let you answer
that only because well I've always seen
what I've seen
but you see more of the game than I have
it looks on on par with ubi worlds which
are real good-looking like honestly I
like how it looks and so did you say
it's better than division one I haven't
I don't know we'd actually have to look
at them side by side cuz your memory of
something isn't necessarily what it is I
like it the safe answer yeah have we
been playing apex Legends yes you know
you guys have been there's been a lot of
shout in the office you think you guys
been enjoying it yeah me and Robby been
playing a decent amount you know like at
the end of day work trying to get some
wins we got one last night that was
pretty cool so yeah bed misses the snow
and happens I can't spot do you need to
shoot all the armor off before doing
damage yes well not all the armor sorry
you just have to break off at least a
piece yeah okay so can i yeah we can't
okay let's do this with other people
it's gonna be way easier leave me alone
I am matchmaking bear I would imagine if
you hit the same spot and then once you
reveal that armor like that one chunk
off like that spot becomes weak and yes
you will probably like kill that enemy a
lot quicker or boss or whatever leader
that's beckon Wow such potty-mouth
I'm just trying to matchmake I believe
me I think that's the other reason why I
couldn't stand LMGs as the reload time
which is they do it should take longer
because you have a hundred clip got a
hundred rounds in that what's up nano
won the game and okay so now I'm
matchmaking okay cool yes let us hope
that playing with someone else still
works this should work out way better
okay
position alright yeah so it seems like
you definitely want to do these missions
with other people uh do you know if
there's weather effects that affect
gameplay yeah I've only seen smoke so
far how do you go rogue in the DZ I mean
technically you just shoot someone in
that it's different actually you have to
hold you have the trigger you have to
hold down a button you can't just shoot
people anymore you have to hold the
button to go rogue and you can also do
it by if somebody dies and you just take
their stuff you go rogue OOP
or if you hack if you hack a UH
see that's like a cache you go rogue and
I'm like yeah it's this way easier with
other people who would've thunk it going
rogues actually it's not as
straightforward as before
for example if another team is rogue and
you kill them you don't you don't go
rogue but if there's like a team that's
rogue hunting another team I don't know
it's confusing sometimes like you you
don't go rogue if you collect a bounty
killing rogue people yeah it makes sense
why would you go rogue if you killed
people that went rogue but if you take
their stuff then you go rogue oh really
yeah so like if you kill the rogue
players and you steal that can send you
rogue interesting okay dances and the
hardest easy you can go rogue by
shooting yeah and the one that rotates
so the the one that is not level
balanced Michael McCarty also saying
holding a button to go rogue thing was
introduced in the first game it was late
in the first game from what I recall
because people were just like going back
and forth in front of other people
yeah that was the best and forcing them
to try to like run into your shots while
you're doing the PvE stuff to force you
Rove yeah I think we just run up to that
last part I actually haven't watched too
much about this game xlx
I am watching as I go here I'm learning
as I go
that box is still there huh did you loot
that box earlier yeah also I'm like
totally it I got a delete going rogue is
that a bad thing depends how you look at
it it means you're basically you're in
like a PvE zone that you can also PvP so
it's like a PvP PvE VEB EVP or PvP
yeah PvP PvE or however you want to say
the acronym
this is the room we had traveling before
I think we'll just Breeze there now that
there's a couple of us live in that m60
life oh yeah there's a there's barn two
left it's that door with a spawn yeah I
mean now we're just gonna breezing
through this never how hard this was so
low that's a good point
anvil one gaming we're currently playing
campaign set yeah well Sean I mean you
can still exploit a game I think without
worrying too much about the grind the
grind is a definitely a part of the game
I mean the mid maxing and all that stuff
is definitely part of the gang or snow
buyer let me get that healing not with
the new system the way works I'm like
dude you're just gonna melt or the
enemies still the same as the division
one not necessarily ah stopping rule
there
stop drop and roll stop setting me on
fire crit spot is always the butt spot
Cannell I'm pissed now you did know my
drone took so long to get to her that it
blew up when I got there I swear to God
I really don't like this new bumper
mechanic Bob Jones Aaron healing and
fire mm-hmm
I see then you just got to get the like
the outfit that lets you hear when
you're standing in fire different
factions is one and then like I think
they some of the enemies have like
different kind of like probabilities and
things like that again we'd have to see
get good please don't worry well we'll
get good gooder I do it doesn't word I
do admit to not being somebody who plays
a lot of cover of a shooters which is
why I'm used to just do using crouch and
prone and it takes some getting used to
you in this game if you are not somebody
who plays cover based shooters and
they're definitely mechanics like going
cover to cover where you get bonuses if
you do it properly
nice who's a clearly your teammates are
marking those guys all right when
they're you got the purple circle on
them there's a I think that the scan
abilities in this game still oh nice
see if they can actually get my journey
to do what I wanted to do yeah
Oh Stu there's a lot of them used
blind-fire for days okay Oh it's cuz the
armor got you
welcome to grenade town dan I would have
been cheap and nice I would have liked I
was trying to see if him holding the
heel while reloading wouldn't actually
reliving it didn't so good job game
seems like some of the shotguns are
definitely way better than other show
xlx crossing dropping some good dark
zone knowledge here three dark zones one
will rotate weekly or so with friendly
fire on glowing rogue is when you steal
become disavowed becoming this about is
after you kill then manhunt after that
probably read par that something's wrong
yeah I didn't like works fine I think
they fixed the friend and buy thing if I
I saw that earlier on their Twitter feed
I'm not mistaken there's definitely
levels of rogue leading up to manhunt
but you can get there by stealing now
two agents the friend invites function
for private beta is currently
unavailable in order for us to fix that
fix certain issues we're having it will
be available again soon let's see if
maybe they don't work Wow Niko bad boy
you came back after getting timed out
that's adorable see you buddy get in
there little robot buddy see the problem
is some 60s that it doesn't have
extended mags which makes it a real m60
so you're somehow a 100 bullets is still
not enough for you no I can get to like
200 and that's before I add another m60
on top of it still not buying it you
just not loving that suppression life
I'd rather use you know one of the
snipers or something again like I said
that some of those uh vector nasty
single-shot guns that do like crazy
amounts of damage in like five shots
there's a SOCOM
Wow I can't remember which gun it was to
be honest it's been so long since I've
played I should have played 1.8 to be
honest but I played Xbox one which
nobody played on and that was a mistake
can you still fully customize a gun yes
well yeah as Erin mentioned I think you
have to actually unlock some of the mod
in your skill your skill stuff in the
White House you have to actually go and
lock it so if you're confused cuz you're
picking up mods but you're not getting
them you have to go and lock it as a
skill unfortunately see that guy's a
sniper the SOCOM I don't know there's
always been a bunch of different
variants of the SOCOM but it's
traditionally been one of the better
probably just say marginals yep timing
it's like 1:30 okay I'm gonna head out
right after this which ring that all my
friends are alive right now okay
what's interesting I haven't seen a
sniper enemy yet knocking I've seen it
but is it that one right there with the
flash the flashlight because all sniper
rifles apparently have flashlights on
them it's like they don't always their
sensor or something you know laser yes
we currently play on PC blind fire it's
the boss is a sniper Oh watch out for
that take your little buddy Oh fire why
with the fire because that's their way
of probably getting around you hiding
behind cover which I can that's
government shooter oh you guys got them
all right wait did you I would assume so
because all the loots right there
see like it's literally faster to just
shoot then to wait for your mind to get
there now no low expectations we did all
right
how long is the story campaign they're
saying that campaign will take you 40
hours there same 40 hours is not a very
long mission that's because there was
with the team can do me a favor can go
to your settings later and swap it to
regular no just show video things
because someone in chat doesn't think
that do they even have a high low medium
ultra thing right now graphics custom I
had to turn brightness up all the way
actually that's something you should
know for this demo I think we were at
high okay so what is ultra all high well
no can't you just go to the top and like
well I mean it'll lose your brightness
one but can couldn't you just set it on
ultra I'm gonna try to find out what
we're at all right just leave it on all
true okay and then change your
brightness if you want so here's what
everything else I think was on either
high or ultros so this 1070 looks like
it can do it but I guess technically we
haven't tried that I'll try but whatever
see I won't say though that I think this
is this game is very optimized for even
lower end rigs because I think and I
have to see it in my person but they
didn't do that video where they're like
comparing different GPUs and it didn't
look like it took a like it looked like
even if you had a lower end it was fine
so I got a BLT do you do you want to
keep going into the dark zone
I think whoa I think I'm probably good
okay we can probably just end it here so
back to this guy thank you guys and gals
and everyone for tuning in we just
checked out the division privates
division - sorry private beta we may or
may not be back tomorrow with endgame I
can't promise you that but we're
definitely have a stream tomorrow at 11
a.m.
Ben and John Luke will be checking out
Geralt in Monster Hunter world any last
thoughts from you and yeah I mean it's
it's more division it's building on top
of all the great stuff they did at the
end of the last game and I think if you
were a fan of division there's
definitely a lot more here for you to
play with but it's a busy launch window
as you said you also might really want
to play anthem which is pretty much out
next Friday for most people or for a lot
of people or you might be playing Far
Cry new dawn there's just a lot to do
right now so we're gonna keep streaming
all of it yeah as it comes up Monday to
Friday 11:00 a.m. Pacific Standard Time
if you haven't hit that sub button you
should so that you guys get notified
when we go alive and when we make cool
features and all that fun stuff and
reviews so until tomorrow we'll see you
guys later